we are here with the cast of Warcraft to
see just how much you guys know about
the world of warcraft
Paula you will be representing the
humans against the orcs first person to
buzz in will answer the question if you
get it right and get a point if you
answer incorrectly you lose a point name
the world in the Warcraft universe led
by humans what is the orc language
called one point in the film the orc
Warriors are fleeing this dying world
Jaina correct she's really taking this
serious true or false the first Warcraft
game let the player choose between
playing and sporks or humans true or
false
Warcraft marks director Duncan Jones
fourth feature-length film true or false
World of Warcraft has had four expansion
sets of so far is correct he's had five
with a six scheduled to release this
September Warcraft editor Paul Hirsch
previously won an Oscar for I'll give it
you stop correct boom
[Applause]
true or false P V e stands for player
vs. that's correct
in the Warcraft poster of Lothar which
side of his face is hidden -
correct true or false the most-watched
warcraft related video on youtube is the
trailer for the film it's true ochre is
playable is a playable race in world of
warcraft true or false
FUS that is correct last question when
will warcraft open June 10 June 10th and
there you go we'll do a tiebreaker here
we go who makes the best sound of an orc
in battle ball you're on the spot that's
you later you win the game what happened
one you both thank you guys so much
Warcraft
[Music]
you
[Music]